bonjour
je prends celui-là je vais prendre
celui-là
je préfère je suis allergique aux
couleurs grises je préfère le blanc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
sinon
non non
comment ça
comme ça
moi je m'en fous de toute manière je
veux pas que vous démarriez moi j'ai
envie de me reposer là une heure dans le
taxi
et je paye ou pas comment je paye ou pas
c'est pas un lieu de repos monsieur vous
pouvez me parler si vous voulez vous
pouvez me parler c'est pas un problème
je vais pas vous déranger non mais juste
pour m'endormir
racontez-moi une histoire quelque chose
je vais rue du Dragon
on y va quand même ben oui
vous emmener à 20 mètres mais pourquoi
pas
pourquoi pas c'est vrai oui mais
je veux bien mais enfin là ça finit par
faire
non plus je vous emmènerai pas c'est pas
la peine
je vais prendre votre numéro vous allez
passer en conseil en conseil
que moi j'ai envie d'aller rue du Dragon
dans votre taxi et que vous voulez pas
voilà et j'ai le droit
mais complètement
vous avez envie de m'emmerder
c'est pas de ma faute si c'est tombé sur
vous
[Musique]
mettez
la publicité
attention attention
[Applaudissements]
et vous en voulez ou pas alors non je
n'en veux pas d'accord je le mets où
c'est ça il faut l'enlever avec un
karcher non non vous l'enlever je vous
ai dit de pas la mettre la voiture et tu
mets ça dessus ouais tu vois les
voitures qui font un peu féminées tu
mets des trucs dessus quoi et ça ça fait
une voiture féminée bon je sais pas moi
j'y connais rien en voiture tu as
entendu ce que je t'ai dit je veux pas
de publicité
tu vas voir ailleurs et puis tu casses
les couilles alors quoi tu me fais chier
là tu comprends pas ou il faut que je te
le dise dégage lâche-moi d'accord en
plus bien FM
oh c'est gay FM
non il y a pas de honte mais on a pas le
droit ah bon c'est interdit ah ouais
c'est pas la Corporation pour
c'est pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
vous le mettez chez vous non ma femme ah
bon elle le sait pas de quoi votre femme
s'il vous plaît monsieur
voilà voilà vous avez non pas du tout
mais là il a senti que vous vouliez pas
le prendre et pourquoi vous marquez
alors supplément chien quatre francs
le règlement mais si j'en prends non
mais vous l'enlevez parce que je vais
avoir du poil partout j'en veux pas
vraiment attendez c'est vrai que c'est
plus la mode le poil partout voilà vous
l'avez stressé la pisser
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
vous pouvez rester là là ça vous dérange
pas
ouais
pourquoi
pour 2 minutes 30 là
[Musique]
vous descendez directement
c'est la nature et personne ne
s'il vous plaît
ça va mieux bonjour
[Musique]
oui mais moi je peux l'accompagner oh là
là
mais il veut pas
il me demande le numéro ça veut dire
quoi ça je sais pas moi de répondre ici
Monsieur puisque j'ai donné le numéro à
qui vous donne le numéro à quelqu'un
pour qu'il m'appelle ici mais vous êtes
fou monsieur et pourquoi c'est mon
portable c'est votre portable
alors le numéro c'est Monsieur c'est pas
un taxi ce qui fait 80
allô bonjour bienvenue à la borne de
taxi 12000 si vous désirez un taxi tapez
étoile
vous avez appuyé sur la mauvaise touche
veuillez réessayer
vous voulez écouter une autre musique
tapez deux
[Musique]
vous voulez écouter une autre musique
tapez 3
si vous désirez un taxi immédiatement
veuillez raccrocher
[Musique]